ce sont les premiers maîtres d'une
fausse minière qui s'étendra sur deux
kilomètres et demi un lieu symbolique
pour tous ceux comme François Legault
qui rêvent de faire du Québec la
batterie du nord-est américain nous
sommes à Saint-Michel des saints 165 km
au nord de Montréal on est au cœur dans
le fond du
gilet en réalité ce sont les paillettes
de graphite donc ici on le voit bien de
soleil là ça ressemble le graphite est
un minerai essentiel dans la fabrication
des batteries électriques pour véhicules
l'entreprise Nouveau Monde graphite
espère que samine entrera en opération
en 2025 ici on a un gisement gagne donc
ici on avait une super minéralogie pour
nous d'avoir accès aux réseaux
électriques d'avoir accès aux routes
d'avoir accès à un bassin d'entrepreneur
local un bassin travailleur le sud-ouest
du Québec dont le sous-sol regorge de
minerai d'avenir comme le graphite et le
lithium est plus convoité que jamais par
l'industrie minière on le constate par
l'explosion des Clems miniers
c'est-à-dire les titres d'exploration
souvent en terre publique qu'un
prospecteur achète pour sonder un
territoire
ici on voit un rouge les secteurs qui
étaient couverts par des clés miniers en
2019 et voici où il y en a aujourd'hui
en 2022 le rouge a éclaboussé le
sud-ouest du Québec l'augmentation du
nombre de Clèves y a été 5 fois plus
rapide qu'ailleurs dans la province
c'est quelque chose de préoccupant pour
chacun des citoyens et les citoyens ne
sont pas au courant de Soyons aucun
information qui peut avoir derrière chez
eux
quelques kilomètres de Clèves c'est
l'organisme de Louis St-Hilaire qui a
réalisé ses cartes précises en épluchant
les données du gouvernement du Québec il
y a des clins qu'on a découvert que
personne connaissait qui sont du côté du
Mont-Tremblant Cédric Klein qui est
aussi grande que le parc du
Mont-Tremblant lui-même c'était pas là
la dernière fois je m'attendais
peut-être à une augmentation quelconque
mais pas de cet ampleur là ça plus que
doublé en pleine mini depuis 18 mois
qui se présente sur le site
aiguille si les terres sont en concluant
on fait une tranchée on va un peu plus
loin on fait un peu de forage comme au
Québec le sous-sol n'appartient pas aux
propriétaires des terrains le processus
d'un clim peut aboutir à des
expropriations lorsqu’un projet a le feu
vert des autorités Nouveau Monde
graphique Nice propriété personne mais à
acheter 25 terrains et neuf maisons à
des voisins parmi tous ces nombreux
clins miniers combien mèneront
réellement à un projet concret comme ici
à Saint-Michel des saints c'est la
grande question ben embêter de vous dire
combien qui pourrait avoir de mines de
lithium de graphite il y en a
quelques-unes qui avance plus il ne faut
pas se laisser impressionner par le
nombre de Clèves dans le sud-ouest de la
province dit l'association de
l'exploration minière du Québec il y a
des titres il y a des clés minières dans
cette région là mais il y a pas d'espace
pour faire d'expansion tant que ça parce
que il y a tellement d'interdictions
partout tout autour
c'est vraiment un enjeu au cabinet du
ministre de l'énergie et des ressources
naturelles on répond qu’il est très rare
que des projets franchiront l'ensemble
des étapes puisque le Québec dispose
d'un cadre légal rigoureux bâti sur les
principes de développement durable c'est
la fierté du Québec de gardaison on a
des ressources puis on les développe de
manière responsable
je comprends que dans certains à
certains égards il y a une approche de
pas dans ma cour puis dans notre cas on
a été capable de contrôler tous les
impacts à l'intérieur d'un kilomètre du
site minier les choix sont cruciaux pour
le développement du Québec et les élus
municipaux veulent être consultés
davantage avez-vous des clins sur votre
territoire oui on en a quelques-uns très
peu la Loi sur les mines et tout de
suite toutes les autres lois donc on le
sous-sol de notre territoire ne fait pas
partie de notre de nos pouvoirs
d'aménagement du territoire donc ce que
ça veut dire c'est que on n'a pas de
contrôle on n'a pas de
le problème est qu'il faudrait qu'elle
se fasse en dehors des zones au moins du
paysage de législature de protéger les
lacs dmrc comme celle des Laurentides on
fait des propositions à Québec mais sans
succès et là on doit déterminer les
zones qui sont incompatibles à
l'activité minière mais on s'entend pas
avec le gouvernement ils ont des
orientations qui sont différentes
d'autres on a présenté des exclusions
mais c'est trop grand ce qu'on a demandé
on nous taouait depuis quelques semaines
une vingtaine de municipalités
s'affichent même ouvertement contre les
mines parce que pertinent de mettre un
moratoire maintenant de prendre le temps
de regarder la situation de changer les
balises pour s'assurer que les milieux
touristiques soient protégées s'assurer
que les milieux écologiques sensibles
soient protégés
au Québec ça va finir qu'on va importer
les substances panières
en pleine course économique mondiale
pour électrifier les transports le
Québec a donc un dilemme à résoudre le
sujet pourrait bien rebondir en campagne
électorale ici jean-Sébastien Cloutier
Radio-Canada Saint-Michel des saints